merci c'est vous que poser des questions
ou s'il fait
[Musique]
oui faisons soir
mes côtés j'ai beaucoup dit je vais le
redire et je pense que j'aurais à le
redire encore beaucoup je ne suis pas
intéressé par la campagne présidentielle
je suis intéressé par la construction
d'un projet éventuellement je ne pose
pas de questions de ceux de cette nature
là parce que je pense que lui enfin j'en
sais rien je ne sais pas s'il durera pas
je sais que je pense qu'il a envie mais
moi j'ai pas envie donc cédé tigana
[Musique]
ah mais je déplorerait toute dissolution
de toute interdiction de livres toute
interdiction de prise de parole si on
interdisait jean luc mélenchon je me
battrai pour que jean luc mélenchon
puisse exister parler je défends juste
un principe j'estime que quand on
commence à interdire de parole des gens
qui qui par l'interdire d'écriture des
gens qui écrivent à interdire de
tribunes des gens qui professent c'est
qu'effectivement démocratie ne va pas
bien moi je suis pour que les gens
s'expriment qu'il des pâtes interdire
n'est pas dans ma culture
non je suis un habitué de la maladie
j'ai fait un infarctus quand j'avais 29
ans j'ai fait un avc et puis après un
autre à baisser puis là le coc vie de je
sortais d'une dingue attrapeurs
martinique
ce que j'ai appris je l'appris quand
j'avais 28 29 ans et que j'ai cru que
j'allais mourir en contre la mort on
doit ce qu'est les jeux pas faire le
fier à bras mais je n'ai pas peur et ne
m'a rien appris d'autres que je ne sache
déjà
du coup j'étais dans un tel état que je
ne m'a rien dû faire c'est à dire je ne
pouvais pas lire encore moi écrit je ne
voulais même pas regardé un film où
j'étais dans des moments
d'hallucinations dans des moments de
transpiration incroyable parce que de
l'eau dans mon lit quand je me
réveillais donc je n'ai pas hésité
france culture que je n'écoute plus sauf
pour confirmer que j'ai bien raison de
ne pas l'écouter
[Musique]
je les projets en matière d'université
populaire
[Musique]